et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
christian bourdeilles président du
souvenir napoléonien danièle obono
députés elle est fille de paris bonsoir
à tous les deux merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france évidemment il y
aura une commémoration par le président
de la république 1 ce sont les paroles
de gabriella talent à l'issue du conseil
des ministres
évidemment pas si évident pour vous
peut-être danièle obono écoutez c'est un
choix politique de fait emmanuel macron
tradi le sens même de ce pouvoir qui
célèbre sur autoroute est réactionnaire
est choisi par exemple de ne pas
célébrer le cinquantenaire de la côte et
on voit bien que dans ce choix via un
choix politique
au delà de la figure historique qui par
ailleurs est enseignée est connu et donc
n'a pas en soi besoin de plus de
notoriété qu'elle en a déjà et ce n'est
certainement pas emmanuel macron
d'affaires découvrir la polio est ce
qu'il a pu accomplir en termes
historiques
donc je crois que le débat qui existe
est légitime parce que encore une fois
c'est pourquoi on choisit cette figure à
ce moment là et pourquoi politiquement
ça pose problème parce que il y a de mon
point dans cet héritage énormément de
choses au public
christian bourdeilles un choix politique
pour danièle obono ont partagé ce
diagnostic
écoutez je crois que c'est pas un choix
politique enfin moi je suis pas à la
place du pré dans la république ce qui
est clair c'est que cette année en 2021
nous avons le 5 mai 2021 qui correspond
donc au bicentenaire de la mort de
napoléon 1er et qui est une grande
figure de notre histoire
donc il n'y a pas à contester ou pas
contester c'est une réalité
et moi je suis président du souvenir
napoléonien
je suis à la tête d'une association qui
existe depuis le 1937 qui n'est pas
complètement nouveau
et parce que napoléon occupe une place
importante dans notre histoire et qu il
a apporté beaucoup de choses
simplement il a apporté le code civil
qui était à l'époque et encore
aujourd'hui c'est notre manière de vivre
ensemble et à l'époque vous pouvez pas
imaginer ce que ça a été donc
d'introduire le code civil c'est à dire
que on avait plus besoin de passer
devant donc un religieux en l'occurrence
un curé et quand on n'était pas de
région que catholiques son mariage
n'existait pas et là avec le code civil
nous avons une avancée considérable ce
que les révolutionnaires ne vais pas
réussi à faire napoléon d'abord premier
consul de la république donc a réussi à
le faire et c'est une ses plus grandes
réussites
s'ils voulaient napoléon c'est l'homme
des réformes et pas des réformes
simplement donc en mots en discours il
les a réalisés et moi je considère que
napoléon 1er consul d'abord de la
république puis empereur des français
est celui qui a sauvé la révolution donc
sans napoléon on risquait fortement
d'avoir un établissement de la monarchie
et les fondamentaux donc de la
révolution n'ont pas été remises en
cause
c'est ça qui est tout à fait
extraordinaire et il faut voir les
dernières années de la période dite
révolutionnaire où les coups d'état se
sont multipliées puisque quand on
n'était pas content du résultat des
élections
eh bien on en voyait donc en prison un
seul homme d'hommes politiques donc
napoléon à stabiliser et toutes nos
grandes institutions aujourd'hui on lui
doit
c'est tout c'est une réalité alors elle
distribue sa part à l'utiliser ou pas
c'est autre chose on va on va continuer
ce débat danièle obono cv vous êtes
d'accord quand même avec une partie du
diagnostic de christian bourdeilles ces
données des institutions c'est l'homme
du code civil ce que aujourd'hui vous
jeter le bébé avec l'eau de barsy jose
employer cette expression un peu
familière à mais pas du tout il compris
moi même j'ai été à une époque très
intéressé par cette histoire j'ai lu
tous les grandes les grands romans de
l'épopée napoléonienne donc encore une
fois il ne s'agit pas de rejeter le bébé
avec l'eau du bain c'est un fait ça a
été un moment de l'histoire important
mais on peut avoir des honda et il
existe y compris en terme de débats
historiques d d d d arguments pour dire
par exemple moi je ne crois pas que
napoléon et continuer la révolution je
pense qu'il y a mis un terme et qui fait
partie de ceux qui ont réussi des coups
d'état et l'installation de l' empire
après la révolution c'est c'est un coup
d'état napoléonien chi chi chi
l'institut il a également alors vous
parliez du code civil mais dans un code
civil qui institue la ferrure isation
des femmes par exemple
donc c'est un code civil patriarcale et
qui n'est pas absolument progressistes
c'est aussi celui qui a rétabli
l'esclavagé contre la révolution
notamment haïtienne une révolution par
ailleurs dont on parle peu qu'on
enseigne peu en france alors que ça fait
partie de notre histoire nationale c'est
quand même cette première révolution qui
s'inspire d'ailleurs de la révolution
française qui établit au bout d'une très
longue guerre et très et très et très
meurtrière et très est très cher parce
que haïti va le payer jusqu'à jusqu'à
très longtemps 7 sept
cette épopée napoléonienne dans les
caraïbes mais on n'en parle quasiment
jamais alors alors danièle obono parce
que jusqu aux membres du gouvernement on
en parle je vous propose d'écouter des
vêtements raynaud un ministre de
l'égalité et de la diversité qui met de
l'eau à votre moulin écouter la napoléon
était l'un des plus grands misogynes que
j'ai jamais lu
il a rétabli l'esclavagé et en même
temps c'est un grand homme de l'histoire
française donc je passe je ne sais pas
bon elle fait du dans le même temps un
christophe bordât ya même temps elle est
au gouvernement question bombay c'est
vrai que ça revient souvent à la
misogynie l'esclavagisme qu'est ce que
vous répondez
écoutez moi je suis pas là pour dire que
napoléon a fait que des choses
extraordinaires
moi je suis donc encore une fois
président d'une société historique qui
s'appelle le souvenir napoléonien
nous nous faisons l'histoire il ya des
aspects positifs pour moi les aspects
positifs l'emportent très largement
encore une fois je vais pas vous faire
la liste de tout ce qu'il a réalisé
il
aspect négatif bien évidemment et gérer
heureusement si je disais pas ça ce
qu'on ne ferait pas de l'histoire ou
s'il fallait faire aussi un débat sur la
république et la troisième république où
on pourra vous dire aussi la 3ème
république c'est la colonisation c'est
jules ferry donc en âme et c'est celle
affaire dreyfus
imaginez une affaire dreyfus sous le
second empire ça serait extraordinaire
ça serait de bonnes occasions mais
malheureusement la sphère dreyfus sas
est passé sous la république la
troisième république donc je crois que
tout régime à ces aspects positifs à ces
aspects négatifs pour revenir à cet
épisode donc de haïti il faut voir qu'il
ya eu des expéditions donc pour rétablir
l'ordre
avant napoléon on dirait que napoléon a
tout fait ce qui n'est pas vrai je
voudrais simplement aussi précisé que la
pression n'a pas rétabli l'esclavagé
il l'a maintenu dans les colonies qui
avait été prise par donc la présence
britannique
d'autre part d'appollo en 1815 c'est
l'homme qui met fin donc au trafic
voilà donc napoléon il est pas raciste
de base
il était comme dans malheureusement
comme beaucoup d'autres à son époque un
et même encore avant puisque certains
disent que veut voltaire était aussi
donc un esclavagiste etc etc on pourrait
élargir ce vaste débat à d'autres
d'autres périodes historiques parce que
l' esclavage à une très longue histoire
malheureusement c'est pas la plus longue
qu'il a inventé lé esclavage dans les
pays du moyen-orient
ça existe depuis de nombreux siècles et
personne n'en parle beaucoup en ce
moment
donc moi je veux bien que napoléon
effectivement a commis des erreurs jeu
est effectivement c'est une erreur j'ai
pas dire le contraire ou encore une fois
je ne suis pas un homme politique je
fais de l'histoire et je suis là pour
rappeler que encore une fois le premier
empire est aussi le second empire ce
sont des pages historique fondamental de
l'histoire de france et qu'on en discute
bien évidemment moi je suis pas contre
qu'on en débatte bien au contraire
moi je suis très heureux que ça crée
donc un débat faisons de l'histoire et
faisons de l'histoire aussi
autour de la république qui a eu
beaucoup de mal aussi à accorder le
droit de vote aux aux femmes puisque
parlons-en aussi la fallu attendre le
général de gaulle qui a priori n'est pas
un homme de gauche
c'est le général de gaulle c'est pas le
front populaire c'est le général de
gaulle par son ordonnance de 1945 à
alger qui donne enfin le droit de vote
aux femmes
donc voilà donc sortons des a priori
politique droite gauche ou pas je
pourrais aussi vous dire que lorsqu'on
appelle le coup d'état du 2 décembre
1851 sa rétabli le suffrage universel
que la république donc avait restreint
donc là aussi c'est pas noir ou blanc
dany faisons l'histoire moi je suis très
heureux quand on fait histoire non
c'est l'occasion en tout cas danièle
obono le fait que napoléon ça soit la
figure l'une des figures historiques
préférée des français devant le général
de gaulle ça ça vous heurte qu'est ce
que ça dit selon vous de la société
française aujourd'hui
ben non je voulais dis moi même j'ai été
très passionné par cette histoire et
j'ai fait de l'histoire à l'université
justement parce que ce sont des moments
extrêmement intéressant donc je ne sais
pas une question de portée et
effectivement je pense qu'il ya le débat
historique et les différentes lectures
qu'on peut avoir de la révolution de l'
empire et des critiques que l'on peut
faire ça c'est une chose et je ne mets
pas absolument pas en cause le travail
des institutions qui font de l'histoire
et qui choisit ce telle ou telle période
le débat qui existe il est politique
parce que effectivement tous les
gouvernements n'ont pas célébré napoléon
sa naissance un moment où ses victoires
militaires
de la même manière et c'est là que c'est
le choix qui est fait alors oui qu'il
soit populaire comme beaucoup de figures
historiques la question c'est aussi
pourquoi est ce que certaines figures
sont célébrés est connu et est transmise
dans l'enseignement et pourquoi d'autres
sont son invisibilité je vous parlais
d'haïti je pourrais vous parler
je reviens sur le sens le cent
cinquantenaire de la commune qui est
aussi parce qu'il fait partie aussi de
cette grande histoire du 10
bien mais des révolutions et qui a qui a
été écrasée dans le sang et dans une
répression très forte
c'est aujourd'hui un événement une
partie de l'histoire mais il n'y a pas
de célébration du gouvernement à ce
moment là et je pense que s'ils écoutent
les figures de la commune étaient plus
connus et les plus célébrées mais
peut-être que ça ferait partie des
figures par exemple louise michel à sa
place de mon point de vue au panthéon de
l'histoire de france et pourtant on
entend peu parler donc encore une fois
je crois que notre histoire c'est celle
de toutes les histoires avec des
contradictions et on en débat la
question et moi ce qui m'interpelle ce
n'est pas que les les français et
françaises trouvent cette figure très
inspirante c'est le choix politique et
idéologique parce que ça renvoie à un
certain nombre de valeurs
qu'est-ce qui est célébrée et je crois
que ça dit beaucoup plus en fait de la
macro ni aujourd'hui de faire ce choix
là que samedi de la société de son
histoire et c'est ça qui m'interpelle et
c'est ça que que je que je critique dans
le choix aujourd'hui pernod grand merci
en tout cas à tous les deux on arrive
déjà malheureusement la fin de ce débat
qu'on reprendra certainement autour du 5
mai merci à vous deux christian
bourdeilles et danièle obono en tout cas
on a compris le message des deux merci à
vous